one of life's success stories you were
head boy at school you had a career in
finance that made you very wealthy now
your prime minister how do you feel when
you lose
sorry how do you feel when you lose
how do you mean that
well you were a winner in life how did
you feel when you don't win oh well look
my my focus in this job is to deliver
for the country I've set out five very
clear priorities to hard inflation grow
the economy reduce debt cut waiting list
and stop the boats all I'm doing every
day is focus on delivering for people
against those five priorities I firmly
believe that that's what the country
wants me to do that's what the
government is committed to doing and
we're working night and day to make sure
that that happens